bonsoir daniel allyn merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rtl france 2 b le
président part dans le brésil qui
affiche un bilan quasi pire que la
première vague comment vous expliquer et
le dire on sait pas quasi pire c'est
effectivement pire parce que si on
regarde les chiffres qu'on a quand il ya
eu la première vague en avril mais on a
dépassé ce qu'on avait en avril mais
c'est un peu la même chose de ce qui
s'est passé en europe avec la deuxième
vague annonce qui est regrettable au
brésil c'est que comme on est un peu en
retard par rapport à l'europe
c'est vraiment dommage qu'ici on n'est
pas fait attention à cette deuxième
vague qui allait survenir en novembre
les cas étaient tombés énormément et
malheureusement ça a repris de plus
belle alors il ya plusieurs facteurs
pour cela un des facteurs fait qu'on a
actuellement dans la ville de sao paulo
deux tiers des patients pour la variante
appelé p1 de manaus une variante qui est
beaucoup plus transmissible et peut-être
beaucoup plus létal
ça c'est le premier détail le deuxième
détail c'est que malheureusement au
brésil qui est un pays quand même assez
pauvre dans son ensemble
cette équation entre rester à la maison
et travailler elle est devenue très
compliquée les subventions du
gouvernement pour ceux qui travaillent
ou qui ont perdu leur travail ou qui ne
sont même pas enregistré comme
travailleur c'est ça a été l'année
dernière plus ou moins de 90 euros par
mois pendant trois mois
c'est largement insuffisant maintenant
parle à nouveau d'une aide de 60 euros
sur trois mois ce qui est aussi
largement insuffisant donc les
brésiliens se trouve face à un double
problème la pandémie qui grâce et qui
effectivement est devenue grave on a
pratiquement dans tout le brésil
90 % d'occupation dans les unités de
soins intensifs
ce qui surchargent terriblement les
hôpitaux et en même temps le peuple qui
a besoin de manger qui donc doit
travailler
donc c'est un double problème c'est très
difficile à régler mais actuellement en
ce qui concerne la pandémie on effectue
man sur un niveau très grave pire ce que
ce qu'on avait en mars avril mai de
l'année dernière quand il ya eu la
première ronde et on a une grosse
difficulté à régler cette
transmissibilité
alors il ya eu des espèces de look down
mais c'est pas du tout les log dingue
qu'on observe en europe qui sont
beaucoup plus riches
le clae goreux ici l'isolément social
est exigée mais il est disons beaucoup
plus lâches
donc finalement vous avez les
agglomérations qui se font de toute
façon sur le transport public avec les
gens qui sont obligés de travailler dans
les services essentiels
vous avez ensuite les cette existence
des favelas ce où on est à cinq ou six
dans une pièce donc malheureusement ça
favorise ça favorise énormément la
transmission du virus donc au brésil
c'est un peu c'est un peu la situation
pour tout le brésil s'est pas seulement
la ville de sao paulo a là où j'exerce
tout le brésil est actuellement sur une
situation très très dangereuse et c'est
vraiment très sérieux alors
manifestement vous n'êtes pas aidé par
le gouvernement on connaît la forme de
déni qui a toujours exercé gène irs1 bol
sonar haut
la population s'en exaspère commence à
s'en agacer justement de cette politique
sanitaire ou cette non politique même
sanitaire du président brésilien
oui ce qui commence à y avoir c'est une
certaine indignation
avec cette espèce de de nous mais lui
est effectivement du point de vue
politique les opinions ont peu changé
on a maintenant la population qui est
vraiment un peu on peut dire un peu plus
irrité et indigné avec ce qui se passe
du point de vue de la pandémie parce que
les gens commencent à se rendre compte
qu'effectivement la situation est très
sérieuse et le président lui il insiste
énormément sur 7 sur cette idée de
reprendre le travail pour que les gens
puissent manger normalement bon dans un
certain sens il a un peu raison mais
malheureusement en milieu de la pandémie
si on fait pas attention on va vraiment
avoir des problèmes donc son appui
politique commence à diminuer
on va voir un peu comment se passe le
restant on commence à vacciner mais sur
un rythme assez lent vu la taille du
pays dans la ville de sao paulo on a
déjà fait pratiquement 2 millions de
vaccins en tout il ya cinq cent mille
personnes
mais malheureusement vu la taille du
pays on et 210 millions d'habitants il
ya eu 20 millions de vaccins utilisés
mais c'est vraiment pas assez vu la
taille du pays avant on puisse endiguer
la la pandémie avec les vaccins sarah
met un certain temps l'estimatif c'est
pour nora vacciner tout le monde ici
seulement à la fin de l'année ce qui
préoccupe énormément
le brésil qui a prouvé en urgence john
seine
une seule dose qu'elle est justement la
situation pourront bien qu'on comprenne
chez vous sur le plan des vaccins vous
en avez combien disponible aujourd'hui
on est actuellement deux vaccins
disponibles le vaccin corona vac qui est
un vaccin fait parler chinois airs
fabriquée ou importée mais partiellement
fabriquée avec les composants primaires
chinois il ya 46 millions de doses qui
vont être distribués jusqu'en mai pour
tout le brésil il est fabriqué dans les
taxes à au boulot et ensuite vous avez
le vaccin astrazeneca anglais qui est
également distribuée dans tout le brésil
vous avez actuellement on a actuellement
pu distribuer jusqu'à maintenant 20
millions de vaccins ce qui représente
quand même un petit pourcentage vu la
population
on a deux vaccins actuellement on n'a
pas encore autorisé le vaccin russe le
spoutnik
on n'a pas autorisé le vaccin janssen
dont malheureusement on en est ces deux
vaccins et le vaccin faille their
moderna mon on l'aura peut-être vers
août septembre ce qui va
considérablement retardé le disons la
diminution de l'épidémie et ce qui
préoccupe tout le monde parce que le
brésil fini par fonctionner comme un
réservoir de virus ce qui peut être
dangereux pour tout le monde surtout
avec cette nouvelle variante et cette
variante p1 de manaus il ya aussi pour
expliquer la situation compliquée au
brésil la question des des variants est
ce qu'on en sait plus sur les variants
aujourd'hui au brésil combien sont ils
alors il ya plus ou moins trois ou
quatre variants qui sont apparus ce qui
préoccupe énormément ce sont ces c'est
la variante p1 mana ours comme je vous
disais deux tiers des cas à sao paulo
sont des cas de cette variante p1
il ya un gros problème est que cette
variante ps et qu'elle même ceux qui ont
eu le qu'ovide l'année dernière
r non pas de protection pour cette
nouvelle variante donc ça fait un double
problème
d'abord toute la population redevient
susceptible avec un virus qui est plus
transmises qui se transmet plus
facilement et qui est hôte est beaucoup
plus létal
merci daniel à vivre médecin conseil du
consulat de france à sao paulo d'avoir
été avec nous en direct pour nous
expliquer donc la situation très
compliquée au brésil merci à vous